[Music]
so I suspect I know the answer to this
but I assume that when Bragg's had
happened you you must have been cheering
through the roof right because that's
probably the first underpinning of some
escape here nope really no you see I am
a contradictory candle oh man
now you're gonna quote somebody else
that's Lika I actually campaigned in
Britain against Prix it and it was it
done found it and none of the people
people said to me you know the European
Union has fixated you they created he
would contempt they drove you out of
government and you are asking us to say
the European Union and my answer was yes
and the reason was twofold firstly you
can't get out by voting to get out
you're not going to get out look at
what's happening now they're going to be
embroiled in the 10-year period of
negotiations instead of becoming
extroverted and looking to the rest of
the world for Britain to become again in
Britannia rules the waves and this
fading nation they can spend the next
ten years completely concentrated
focused on negotiations of get them
nowhere with Brussels so basically just
the process of extra cating themselves
out yes yes and I use the the last line
in Hotel California you can check out
any time you like with it anyway yeah
yeah so given that that is the case and
you don't want to leave and completely
sever your links with the European Union
because you're a part of Europe 60% of
your trade is with Europe okay so you
can't just say how could I forget about
it you're gonna have economic implosion
in Britain that's going to affect the
you know the most underprivileged people
the and and and and they're the ones who
want to brakes it so I was in and just
be fearful of that which which you pray
for I was saying to them and my line was
and the European Union is a terrible
thing it's not about that nobody knows
this better than me but what I think you
should do you should forget leaving
we should bind forces to get
within this awful union and fight
against the powers that be within you
but join pull puller forces together
within Europe so for instance you know
if let's say in the United States you're
against the federal government the
solution is not to up stamps and declare
that California is going to be an
independent republic what you should be
doing as Patriots as sensible Americans
is buying together across the United
States to change the federal government
institution change the Constitution if
you want but the solution is not
fragmentation fragmentation you see is
it let me put this way I'm just and I'll
conclude with this if we had not created
this European and I would fight tooth
and nail against its creation to the
nail against its creation and like I
fought against relation realism but it's
one thing to say we should not have
created it it's quite another to say
let's now break it up right because if
you break it up you don't go back to
where you would have been if you dated
you fall off a cliff because imagine if
the European Union now breaks up what's
going to happen there's going to be a
fault line across the river rhine
splitting France and Germany again
there's going to be a stagflation Airy
Latin Europe Italy France with inflation
and high unemployment because those
currencies are going to devalue
massively so they're going to convene
tation and we'll be unblinding so
stagflation not very nice whereas in
German you're going to have deflation
you're going to have millions of workers
who are now working poor becoming
unemployed for this is a frightening
prospect yeah this is how work in so
this is why I was against Brick City
because you need to see ahead and the
solution for me must be paneer appear
now I mean this is fascinating so I
guess I would describe you at this point
as a mark as a libertarian did you say
mark this libertarian or libertarian
Marxist either way either way but you
gotta add realist into that right but I
guess that's that frames it because
basically what you're saying is there's
a sucky situation here but that doesn't
mean that that leaving is the
answer yeah so so we're dealing with a
lot of macro stuff here on the micro
level for the average person that's in
Athens right now you know for somebody
that lives a block away from you let's
say they had a little bit of money and
they wanted to open a store could they
literally not get a dime from a bank
right now yes so banks are David let me
give you just one number yeah
so that you understand why I'm saying
fifty five percent this is a percentage
of all loans given out by Greek banks
which are non performing as we speak
nonprofit can you imagine a bank whose
loan book is in the red by fifty five
fifty five percent of the loan book
being non-performing yeah that's fine
hurry up they're insolvent so they know
they're insolvent so anytime they get
they hold on to because they know that
the central bank the authorities can
declare them insolvent at any moment the
fact that they are not doing it is
because the authorities fear they they
do it then there will be a complete you
know collapse of all the banking system
throughout Europe because they are all
in the trouble thing of attacking banks
five banks German banks Deutsche Bank
for God's sake you know friend French
banks but nevertheless if you're a
banker in Greece let's say you own alpha
bank or youdo bank these are Greek banks
and make some money comes in you hold on
to it you do not lend it out because you
want to shore up your capitalization and
the result is that I have a friend who
has a factory small factor it used to be
bigger than out it's smaller up in
central Greece and this is a very good
case in point because he has a very good
track record his company has been
profitable even in the middle of the
crisis over the last decade and the
reason is because 95% of what he
produces he exports its plastics manga
so he 95% of output goes out celebrates
so that's why he's been shielded from
the crisis so recently I was talking to
him and he said to me that if he manages
to survive it in July 2017 groups would
be it would be great feat and so why
you're profitable so yeah I'm profitable
but you know what my supply is he gets
his raw materials from abroad no longer
except Greek bank letters of credit so
he has to pay for he supplies from his
own pocket and that is crippling for any
any business yeah so he he has he has
unfulfilled orders because he's
constrained in terms of his inputs
because the banking system does not work
and then so I pushed him a bit further
and said so why don't you go to the
German bank ask them for money I mean
there they must be dying to give you
money because you're you know you have a
good business and they don't have enough
customers so it's a match made in heaven
so don't you think I haven't done it I
went to Frankfurt you know what they
said to me bring your headquarters to
Germany and we'll give you loans well
now that's not how to run any monetary
union right right that's that's how you
basically rape and pillage everybody and
and centralize everything so do you
think that there's a sort of net gain
here of what this is done for the Greek
people just in terms of national pride
now I know national pride can always go
awry but I was even watching the the
Anthony Bourdain show on CNN a couple
days ago and they did a whole thing
about Greece it was mostly about food
but they talked a little bit about the
economic situation and I heard a bunch
of people say that there there's a sort
of newfound sense of pride because they
do feel like their backs are against the
wall
now you do sense that when we you know
when we win in government and I'm not
saying this because I I was part of it
but I think this is quite objective and
that know that we said to Germany to the
creditors for a few months that
resistance caused a sense of pride to
skyrocket and then of course it was
dashed the night of the referendum we
discussed but to this day you're right
Greeks have capacity to do two things to
extract tried out of survival to say
that look we're still alive you know you
have not managed to force us to migrate
yet
and also to extract to extract a lot of
joy out of misery we are very good at
that English yeah because we've had
centuries of poverty centuries of
occupation remember this was under was
under the ottomans attacks for a good
500 years and we survived so we're very
hard to kill that's a key to the whole
thing here yeah very hard to kill yeah
and especially the killer spirits you go
out Nigerian it's a Tuesday night if you
go out now to the centre of Athens
you'll find people dancing and singing
and of course the the songs can be
melancholy they can be very bitter they
can be very sad donek and ironical but
you know there's a revival of the arts
which is a good same thing nineteen
thirties was it was very good for music
and the arts and cinema and theatre
because generally the human spirit and
the human condition is a remarkable
capacity to respond to hardship with
creativity so we see that there are
silver linings I'm curious is do you
know of a Greek mythology that's sort of
the right metaphor for all this I love
Greek mythology when I was a kid and I
was this morning I kept trying to come
up with something that would feel like
the right answer is there a story in
Greek mythology that gets us close to
what's going on right now
plenty yeah give me was give me one what
the bailout says Sisyphus Sisyphus is
pushing the rock up the hill and he's
condemned this is his punishment the
moment he reaches the the top there are
girls back in history to the game and
the optimal strategy for is
to stop pushing it up the hill this was
my view about the bailouts right the
optimal strategy was to stop doing yeah
like that was pretty on point now I want
a couple more okay and a second one is
the Ulysses strategy which I really
enjoy it was what I was trying to
convince my fellow ministers in cabinet
that we should be doing it recall the
story when he leases Odysseus his Greek
name is on his ship and he's trying to
sail back to Ithaca to his hometown to
his home own Island and um this is a
story of MA
to pool challenges of his faces and on
his way back home one of the challenges
is that this is this island inhabited by
famous singing women called the silence
yeah silence were infamous for their
wonderful singing their melodic singing
is singing the most beautiful voices in
the world but also for their cruelty
because they used the singing to lure
sailors to the island and then they
slaughtered them and ate them so he
wanted to combine together to have his
pie an idiot he wanted to listen to
their song and not die so that his
strategy was he asked his crew members
to plug the AA's with wax so they
wouldn't hear the song to tie him up on
the mast and sail past the island so he
would hear the song but not to listen to
him at all not paying attention to him
to his gesticulations and you know his
protestations let me out of it now until
they were well clear of the end so I was
saying to my colleagues this is the you
know forget the silent song if you want
to listen to it we have to tie ourselves
up on an imaginary mast must be a
commitment not to take another penny
from Europe until we our debt is
restructured and to have a sensible
fiscal policy because if we take any
money this is like succumbing to the
siren song so that's another and finally
yes I give you three yeah three is a
good number and the story of Antigone
Antigone was young princess in Thebes it
shows a tragic figure her two brothers
we're on the wrong they were involved in
a civil war they were fighting amongst
each other as to who would become King
and the result is that they both died on
the battlefield
the sitting king of Thebes who was
Antigone's uncle decided that one of
them wasn't around one of the two
brothers the one who had attacked the
city in order to claim the throne from
brother and therefore and whereas his
brother would be given full military
honors and a wonderful funeral the the
body would be led left rot and to be
eaten by jackals on the battlefield and
Antigone who thought who believed deeply
and religiously that it doesn't matter
at all what you think about a man's
deeds everyone deserves a proper funeral
she defied her ankle king and buried her
brother there's up being that she was
executed and there is a wonderful speech
in the in Antigone the tragedy in which
she explains beautifully that when the
right contradicts power right should
prevail so yeah three stories all right
well I love that's a perfect way to to
end this I hope the next time we can do
this in person because as I told you
before I'm overdue to visit Greece
where's the best spanakopita in Athens
oh my goodness um you'll find a lot of
good spanakopita you don't need to go to
one place but there's one a place around
the corner from where I live yeah
alright fair enough you don't have to
you don't have to actually say that
while we're while we're on air all right
well it was a pleasure talking to you
and and you know it's a mess but but
good luck I guess you know it is a mess
David but at the same time it's a mess
that we all find ourselves in the only
reason why Greece matters is because
it's an it's indicative of what is wrong
with our world at large Greece should
not matter to people in America and so
on my mother's to people in Greece but
it is interesting that that the denial
of the establishment to deal with what
it is in the end a simple to solve
problem of financial engineering and
some fiscal policy they are denial to do
it is a political failure which I think
reflects the reasons why all our
countries in the United States in Europe
the whole world is in trouble because we
have a political a scandalous political
absolutely well it just combines so many
things that I'm talking about all the
time and it's been a pleasure talking to
you and for more on Yan is's work you
can go to his website which has a ton of
his articles it's a great site it's
Yanis varoufakis dot-eu
and we'll have the link right down below
Yanis thanks a lot
[Music]